.
SIMPLE.
SENATOR TED CRUZ, THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US.
HERE WITH MORE REACTION WE HAVE
THE TEXAS ATTORNEY JIM PAXTON
AND FLORIDA ATTORNEY GENERAL.
LET'S START WITH YOU, JIM.
TO ME, BETWEEN GOVERNOR ABBOT
AND GOVERNOR DE SANTIS THE BEST
POLITICAL JUJITSU EVER IN
HISTORY AND THE IMPACT AND LOOK
AT THE RANK.
>> NO.
IT'SOGIST, IT'S AMAZING.
THEY'VE DONE AN AMAZING JOB.
THEY'VE HAD TO DEAL WITH THIS
CRISIS OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
AND I LOVE THAT THEY'RE
HIGHLIGHTING THE HYPOCRISY THAT
YOU AND SENATOR CRUZ GEST ABOUT.
THEY'RE DEALING WITH A FEW, WE
DEAL WITH 5 THOUSAND A DAY AND
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH THIS FOR
ALMOST TUYERES.
AND AS SENATOR CRUZ TALKED
ABOUT, DEL RIO, A TOWN OF 36
THOUSAND HAD 50 PERCENT MORE
PEOPLE SHOW UP AT THEIR DOOR AND
HAD TO DEAL -- THERE WAS NO
COMPLAINING BY THE LIBERAL
ELITE, NO COMPLAINING BY GAVIN
NEWSOME.
WE HAD TO DEAL WITH IT, AND WE
HAD NO HELP.
>> LOOKING AT RON DE SANTIS HE
POINTED TO WHAT, 70 JACKSONVILLE
ALONE OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
DROPPED OFF IN FLORIDA IN THE
DARK OF NIGHT.
FLORIDA IS NOT NOT SANCTUARY
STATE, AND THEY DON'T SUPPORT.
HE SAID OKAY, WE'LL SEND THESE
ILLEGAL EMIGRANTS TO PLACES THAT
CLAIM TO BE HAVING SANCTUARY.
STATUS.
TO ME THAT SEEMED THE FAIR THING
TO DO.
>> IT RELATES TO FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION POLICY SINCE THE
FIRST MONTH IN OFFICE AND
REPUBLICAN STATES LIKE - - US
AND FLORIDA HAVE BEEN FIGHTING
THEM EVERY INCH OF THE WAY.
BUT THEN.
COMING OVER.
WE'VE BEEN BEGGING, JUST THEY
DON'T COME, THEY WON'T.  EVEN
HAVE FOLKS THAT ARE TRANSPORTED
TO FLORIDA BY AIR AND MURDER
SOMEONE.
THEY DESERVE THIS, THIS IS A
HYPOCRISY, AND IT'S ALL TRUE.
THIS IS A NECESSARY EXERCISE.
SOME POINT, THEY ARE IN THIS
BUBBLE.  THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON.
WE HAVE TO GET ON THEIR DOOR
STEP TO FORCE THEM TO SEE WHAT
IT TAKES TO DEAL WITH RECORD
BREAKING SURGE OF FOLKS FLOODING
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
THE MOEM IT'S LIKE MUPPETS
OFFERING COMMENTARY AND OPINING
ON WHAT EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE TO
DO DEAL WITHING THIS ON A DAILY
BASIS AND DEAL WITH THEIR
RECKLESS DANGEROUS POLICIES.
PASSES THE POLICY THAT BREAKS
THE LAW SHOULD HAVE TO LIVE IN
IT.
>> YOU KNOW, I AGREE, ASHLEY.
DO YOU BELIEVE GOVERNOR DE
SANTIS WILL KEEP THIS UP?  I
HOPE HE DOES.
AND I'LL THEN I'LL ASK THIS Y
QUESTION.
>> THE FUNDING TO DO SO AND IN
ORDER TO START GETTING SOME OUT
OF WASHINGTON WE'VE GOT TO FORCE
THEM TO SEE WHAT EON THE FRONT
LINES, LAW ENFORCEMENT,ER ARE
DEALING WITH.
THEY'RE GOING TO START TAKING
ACTION AND IF THE AMERICANS SEE
IT MAYBE THEY'LL START HOLDING
THIS PRESIDENT ACCOUNTABLE.
>> AND KEN, WILL GOVERNOR ABBOT
CONTINUE, I BELIEVE HE SHOULD
CONTINUE AS WELL.
>> YEAH, THIS WAS HIS IDEA.
IT HIGHLIGHT THE HYPOCRISY THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND WE'RE
TALKING AGAIN A FEW THOUSAND, A
DROP IN THE BUCKET COMPARED TO
WHAT WE'VE DEALT WITH.